[Music]  this might be another way that we're  similar i i rev high and then at night  my wife just passes out and i'm moving  around and talking to the coat rack and  waking the kids up and doing bits for  them  do you what do you use anything to help  you go to sleep at night you're so cute  um well i did and i've i've kind of  weighed myself ambient as you know  you do go to sleep but i don't get a  full night's sleep on ambien because i  would night eat i had a chicken wing and  a pop-tart you did that sleep eating yes  i woke up with a chicken wing from kfc i  loved kfc  what i want to know is was the chicken  wing in the house before you went to  sleep or did you go to kfc on ambien i i  did not go but it was leftover and then  tweeting on ambien  don't do that either i've been like  watching crime shows and i'm like don't  go on a cruise you'll never return  especially if you're a honeymoon or a  punk  [Laughter]  melatonin